In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 8 on which we commemorate the Holy New
Martyr, Monk Ignatius, the memory of the Holy Monk and New Martyr, Saint Ignatius the New.
Saint Ignatius was born in the province of Thronovo in Bulgaria at the end of the 18th century.
He was named John by his pious parents who put him to the study of the Holy Scriptures
and the Slavonic tongue.
Since from childhood he had desired to lead the angelic life.
They let him enter the monastery of Rila.
Where he bore with patience the extreme harshness of his spiritual father, who incited by the
devil actually tried to kill him so that John had to flee.
Meanwhile his father had been killed by the Turks for refusing to serve in the army against
the Christian Serbs and his mother and sisters were forced to deny Christ.
Upon further persecution John fled to Bucharest where he became a close spiritual friend of
Saint Athemios who, having in the past denied Christ, was soon to offer himself for martyrdom.
John fled from place to place to escape the Turks and eventually reached the Holy Mountain
of Athos where he had long desired to dwell.
He stayed for a little while at the monastery of Rigurio and then put himself under the
spiritual direction of the Hieromunk Basil of Saint Anne's Skeet.
He accompanied his spiritual father to Thessalonica and happened to be present at the martyrdom
of Saint David commemorated on June 26th.
This made such an impression on him that from then on he wanted nothing so much as to offer
himself as an acceptable sacrifice in imitation of the Savior.
On his return to the Holy Mountain he became a monk, taking the name Ignatius and through
aesthetic labors began to train for his final contest of martyrdom.
He obtained at last the blessing of his spiritual father to go to Constantinople and fulfill
his desire.
He went to the judges palace there, boldly trampled on the Muslim turban and confessed Christ,
upheld by the prayers of all the Christians of the city, he rejected every condition offered
by the Turks to spare his life and willingly gave himself up to death.
He was hanged on the 8th of October in the year 1814.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.